[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous la nouvelle
formule de 5 à 10 à l'occasion des
municipales
nous allons recevoir bertrand carruggi
mois en alternance les candidats aux
élections de 2020 chaque candidat aura
cinq minutes pour s'exprimer ce matin
nous recevons nous recevons fabrice du
nom bonjour bonjour à niveau rue bonjour
la martinique bonjour le lamentin vous
êtes la tête de liste du mouvement le
lamantin la relève quelles sont vos
motivations fabrice d'une amp aux offres
y aller pourquoi jésus se serait
répondre à la question pourquoi être
mais vous savez il y a deux hommes
distinctement qui m'ont dit leur après
l'autre être mère aujourd'hui c'est
gérer la misère du monde et un autre m'a
dit est ce un éminent journaliste qui me
disait que vu la responsabilité
judiciaire à qui incombe aux mets quant
à la responsabilité d'actions qu'il faut
être fou aujourd'hui pour être mère elle
est à ces deux hommes là je réponds que
je suis fou du lamentin que je suis fou
de la martinique que j'ai envie de
servir parce que si nous ne mine si nous
ne mettons pas au service des uns et des
autres des plus faibles des plus démunis
si nous n'avons pas une vision pour le
développement de notre commune de notre
pays qui va le faire à notre place
je suis issue d'une génération où les
choses ont été assez difficiles mais
issu d'une famille issue d'une commune
qui m'a donné toutes les chances pour
être celui que je suis aujourd'hui
et le temps est venu de rendre
conformément à ce que nous enseigne et
frantz fanon que chaque génération dans
une relative opacité une mission à
accomplir
il est temps que ma mission sa complice
c'est à dire servir le lamentin et
servir du mieux que je pouvais tout
l'envié de la volonté la bonne volonté
qui m'anime quels sont les axes
prioritaires de votre campagne
les axes prioritaires se définissent je
pourrais dire surtout à point il
faudrait que le lamantin retrouve tout
ça toute son autonomie d'action
politique afin de pouvoir servir au
mieux les laventie en italie
mais vous savez que ce n'est pas le cas
j'ai déjà donné l'exemple ci et là de
l'eau vous voyez que par rapport aux 10
6 et le pacte
il y a un apn m le maire actuel du
lamentin pieds et mains liées et il ne
plus rien dire
et jusqu'à maintenant les coupures
successives se font au détriment des
usagers sans qu'il n'y ait quelques
réponses qui leur soit apportée
donc il ne s'agit pas pour moi d'entrer
dans un conflit avec qui que ce soit
mais il faut qu'on soit sopo on a été
élu c'est à dire le défenseur du peuple
le défenseur des administrés l'âme
antigua vous avez ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point le deuxième
point il faut qu'il y ait une
revitalisation effectif du bourg qui
verra dit les quartiers et ceci va se
faire avec
en partenariat avec les habitants du
bout avec les commerçants du bourg et
avec un plan efficace de développement
urbain temps en marche douce temps en
développement doux mais aussi en
développement soit voiture mais aussi
bus parce que le tcsp doit être
efficient pour le lamantin ce qui n'est
pas encore le cas et si je me souviens
bien il y avait un projet je crois c'est
el kalb acier si ça vous vous parler
d'un projet qui ont monté un alignement
aujourd'hui nous nous inscrivons dans la
réalité
vous avez vu l'état du calebasse y est
vous avez vu comment ce projet si j'ai
envie de dire qu'il est mort né il n'est
pas de mon intention de faire des
poussées à quiconque mais nous devons
nous inscrire dans un pragmatisme dans
une réalité pour que le l'inventeur on
trouve toute sa superbe troisième point
le le troisième point il faudrait qu'il
y ait comme je le dis là une ville
prospère ses habitants prospère le
bien-être le bien vivre parce que vous
vous rendez compte qu'aujourd'hui un
couple laventinois une famille
laventinoise qui a envie de sortir et ça
c'est un exemple parmi tant d'autres qui
ont envie de sortir avec ses enfants ne
peut pas le faire sous les lamantins est
obligé d'aller soit robert soit trinité
sous le bord de mer ou encore home à
l'école ou encore h et cher ça c'est un
exemple parmi tant d'autres il faudrait
que nous ayons un pied vivre dans notre
commune aujourd'hui les enfants
laventinois ne serait ce qu'au niveau de
la caisse des écoles qui va se retrouver
être matraque et si l'équipe actuelle
repasse ce que je ne désire pas du tout
il faudrait que les enfants laventinois
et toutes leurs chances pour qu'il y ait
une réussite scolaire efficiente
il y est qu'il y ait une politique
inclusif
pour ces enfants là quelle que soit leur
catégorie socioprofessionnelle en
sachant que si on dit que la vente est
une ville riche
l'amandinois ne sont pas riches
aujourd'hui de 42 conscient de
l'amandinois paient l'impôt sur le
revenu donc il est temps de se mettre au
service de tout le monde aujourd'hui
avec la baisse des dotations de l'état
le changement annoncé de l'octroi de mer
comment financer ce programme que vous
avez commencé financer cela j'ai fait
preuve à la ville y voyez vous le savez
d'ingénierie financière dans une autre
commune aujourd'hui nous avons
suffisamment de moyens suffisamment dax
et de lever financiers sur lesquels
actuellement les administrations rares
sont celles qui appuie dessus pour faire
des collectes de fonds publics
il faudrait que nous nous asseyons et
que nous arrêtions d'avoir comme seule
doctrine de taper dans le porte-monnaie
des lames anti noirs des administrés
mais au contraire de s'asseoir de
prendre le temps de penser les projets
de prendre le temps et c'est ce que j'ai
fait pendant ces deux dernières années
ne prendre le temps de penser les
projets et qu'il y ait une crédibilité
dans l'action fabrice du nom je vous
remercie mon harnais l écoute de nos
gros gras c'est moi qui vous remercie